(upbeat music)
- Hi everybody, today I'm gonna talk
about another topic regarding entomology,
specifically the importance of migration
to butterfly and moth populations.
Migration is a very important
part of the life cycle
of lots of butterflies and moths.
Although it's not, it's not
very common to be honest,
there's a lot of species,
the majority of butterflies
and moths species are fairly sedentary,
meaning they have very focused ranges,
and they don't migrate much.
But there are notable exceptions,
and the way humans behave, and
the way humans are stewards
of their environment is very important,
to be able to map, and track
and also protect the migration routes,
of these particular butterflies and moths.
So probably the most important migrator,
that I'm sure everybody has heard about,
is the monarch butterfly.
The monarch butterfly is very well known,
and it is a very strong migrator,
at least most populations are.
And this species as an
adult, ranges from Canada,
all the way to Mexico,
and individuals over winter
in the mountains of Mexico
in the fir forest at high elevation.
And they have spectacular
breeding aggregations
in the mountains of Mexico.
So a lot of people have a little,
have some misconceptions about migration,
like what do they do?
Do they all do make the flight at once?
But they don't necessarily
make the flight at once.
So this is the example
of the queen butterfly,
which is the same genus,
same family as the monarch,
and the queen butterfly
doesn't migrate very much, very rarely.
Most of these live in the Southeast US,
down into the Caribbean and
also central and South America,
and they have a very sedentary existence,
they don't migrate much.
The monarch starts off
in the spring in Mexico,
and individuals fly up through,
basically through Mexico,
into the Southern United States,
through Texas and
California and reproduce.
So an individual monarch doesn't go
from Mexico to say New
York or Connecticut.
It will have several generations
that it takes to get up,
from Mexico to like
basically the Northeast,
because the butterflies
don't live that long,
there's a lot of challenges along the way.
So the butterflies that you're seeing now,
like in the fall in Connecticut
are going to be several gen,
are going to be like one
or two generations separate
from the moths that left
Mexico in the spring.
And then, basically when there's
to get these subtle cues
from the environment,
they turn around and
decide to return to Mexico,
which is a mystery that
science is still trying
to figure out how they do this.
But it's like when it gets cooler,
the monarchs turn around and
start flooding back South,
usually along the coast.
And a lot of people will see a lot
of monarchs around this time of year,
because monarchs are extremely,
like they're very sensitive to cold,
so they cannot survive winter
temperatures in the Northeast,
so they have to immediately return South.
So over multiple generations again,
these, a lot of adult
monarchs will actually move
from, say the Northeast
down to the mid Atlantic,
or the Southeast, and then
have another generation.
And then those next generation
monarchs will continue
to Mexico or the Caribbean.
So again, a single monarch,
usually doesn't make the whole trip.
There might be a few that
are strong enough to do it,
but most of them take
a couple of generations to make the trip.
And so given basically
how we can affect migrators
becomes very apparent
when I talk about these next two species,
which are called, this is
the common painted lady,
which if you have children,
a lot of people sell
rearing kits for these,
where children can rear,
and rear butterflies from eggs to adult,
and they're called painted ladies,
they're very common species.
And this butterfly here is
called the common snout,
they're called snouts,
'cause they have a little,
like their palps are
kind of pointed into a,
it looks like a nose, this
is another migratory species.
And sometimes in the Southwest,
these things are so abundant
that there could be literally
swarms of billions of them,
flying through the Southwest,
and people have drove through them,
and just darkens the skies,
there's so many of these.
So when it comes to migrators,
the common denominator
in a lot of these is the Southwest.
So in the Southwestern United States,
you have a lot of concentration
of butterfly diversity.
And a lot of our species that
we get up into the Northeast,
of all different types,
pass through that area.
And so a big challenge for
going forward for humanity,
is to actually protect the areas,
not only in Mexico, in Latin America,
where these species is over winter,
but also protecting habitat,
that these species use as corridors,
to basically fuel up for their journey.
So old farmland, old fields,
abandoned areas with flowers,
are very important for
basically preserving the habitat
of these butterflies and moths.
And a lot of these
butterflies actually feed on,
like these feed on milkweeds.
So if you have milkweeds in your yard,
don't, don't chop them down, keep them,
because these butterflies will use them,
both for fueling the next generation,
and also food for nectaring.
So, and another issue is
associated with the border wall,
that's unfortunately being proposed
to going up along the Texas
and New Mexico and California border.
And this wall is having the adverse effect
of potentially destroying
lots of key habitat,
for butterflies and moths
right along the Texas border.
And there's a very strong center
of diversity in Southern Texas,
it's one of the most species rich areas,
of all the areas of the
United States for butterflies,
and actually the butterfly,
one of the major butterfly
gardens in Southern Texas
is actually partially
destroyed by construction crews
that are building the wall.
So even by doing things that seem
to be based more focused on humans,
they have adverse impacts
on the environment,
by causing that
destruction to the habitat,
both to the plants that
the insects depend on,
and also killing potential
caterpillars eggs and pupa
of adult butterflies and moths as well.
(upbeat music)